I've been watching these guys for a very
long time I feel like that they are
spearheading a really dope movement of
financial literacy in the hip-hop
community and communities of color and
just younger Generations I've learned a
lot from y'all man we got to earn your
leisure podcast in the building what's
going on what's up what up what up
what's good uh first things first how
did y'all link up
um we grew up together so um
he's two years older than me so uh I was
in sixth grade and he was in eighth
grade and at the time there was a
remember this movie Eddie uh yeah Whoopi
Goldberg would you coach the news yeah
it was um they had extras and so they
they took a group of kids from our
neighborhood and we went to Madison
Square Garden and we were extras in the
movie we actually never made the Final
Cut but it was pretty dope experience to
be on a movie set so
I was always hanging around with older
kids my whole life
um so everybody knew me because I was a
different school but I didn't know him
because he was new to the neighborhood
so um we were all there and I was always
kind of like introverted so I just
stayed to myself so everybody was
talking to me and he came over and he
just like was talking to me like he
already knew who I was and I'm like who
is this why is he talking to me like so
that's the first time that we met on
this set of a movie
um I was like 12 he was probably like
14. and yeah we just been friends ever
since y'all been rocking ever since yeah
yeah yeah what was like for me because
like well
this is a random curve because you guys
were an Eddie
I do have a random when I watch these
basketball movies that get filmed and
there's like real NBA players in them
and like people in the crowd I always
wonder if they go in and they like pause
a game oh yeah no and they're like all
right guys this is for a movie or do
they like do a whole fake game it's a
whole so like what happened was they
took us to the garden and they let us go
on the court and like if we made a shot
there was people in the crowd they would
chill but it would be cheering for us
and so then obviously they would cut in
between live footage of real games okay
but the the audience reaction would be
actually us on the court that was the
first time we actually got paid for
anything were any of the Knicks actually
there so what's so funny is that they
weren't in the movie but we we were in
the garden so they had a game that day
so we were seeing as we were like
wrapping up the shoot we saw some of the
Knicks come in yeah what's the era here
is this like Charlie Ward like this is
Charlie
Allen Houston Davis yeah I saw him come
off and they were
um if I get the daycare they were
playing the Pistons wow so it was like
Grant Hill was coming to the Garden so
you know what's so crazy is that now
forget this Hubert Davis walks in right
and it's a group of us and um like we
was like little kids like 12 13 years
old so we seen Huber Davis like Hubert
what's up man because like can we get
your autograph
and he just looked and just kept and
kept walking and he's not the guy I
think we might walk him to him that's
why Jordan would be killing you or
something like that that's why no one's
that's why Mitchell we're making your
jersey well and I just it's just crazy
because it's like you know 20 years
later and I still remember that so it's
you got to be careful how you treat
people because you never know right and
it's like that's something that even now
to this day we try to you know
accommodate people the best thing that
we possibly can and if we can't
accommodate it we'll try to like let you
know why we can't do this and we got to
catch a flight we gotta go I never
forget like we was little kids and we
saw him and he was not interested in
stopping at all as a kid I had great
experiences with some NBA players
but there was two one of them it's okay
because it was Charles Barkley he was an
[__] outside of a Cardinals game
but the other guy George McLeod's bum
ass from the sons
you remember George McCloud like a fake
3-and-d guy before three and D was a
thing [__] George McLeod he was